[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
happy Monday everybody
[Music]
oh man got a lot to talk about in
today's monologue so like Anna Navarro
in front of a plate of churros
let's Dive In
I love churros so it appears musk might
actually resign as Twitter CEO now I'm
not sure if Jack Dorsey will come back
but he'll continue not showering just in
case
over the weekend weekend we gone
must ask the Twitter Community should I
step down as head of Twitter I will
abide by the results of this poll
God if only Biden would take the same
poll
but we can dream
then musk followed up with be careful
what you wish as you might get it that's
something I learned the hard way when I
wished for geraldo's friendship
foreign
so after 17 and a half million votes the
final result 57 percent said yes Elon
should step down 43 said no although
we're still waiting for results from
Maricopa County
[Laughter]
see that one coming huh you know
but that's a 14 point difference pretty
wide margin I don't know if we can blame
the Dems for stealing this one too so
they got they still got plenty of votes
from dead people including Keith
olberman
do it but I have enough on my plate with
this show the five and my weekends
teaching spot welding to those sick
brats at the orphanage
foreign
I hate charitable work
still giving but there are some
available people out there Hunter Biden
for example be honest be honest he can
make it rain in the boardroom and the
VIP room
he'll knock up your stock price like a
pierce stripper and two inch heels
because he did Jimmy phela because
everyone hates him already
Gregory thank you girlfriend
Donald Trump let's face it being Twitter
CEO is all the fun of being president
without being president
you can still torture the media without
having to smell Jim acosta's horrible
breath
and Trump's less filtered than my
goldfish Aquarium those guys sure are
good at floating upside down
I know how about Brian kilmina
who knows how he'll handle Twitter but
it can't be worse than his life
I know
that's terrible Hillary Clinton if she
can hey if she can sense her then she
won't have to murder
yes good one also happening over the
weekend the latest batch of Twitter
files were dumped showing that the FBI
rattled Twitter execs over not removing
stuff that upset them journalist Matt
taibi tweeting the revelations quote
Twitter's contact with the FBI was
constant and pervasive as if it were a
subsidiary he showed that between
January 2020 and November 2022 there
were over 150 emails between the FBI and
Twitter execs and many were requests by
the FBI for Twitter to take action on
Election misinformation even involving
joke tweets and lo from low follower
accounts and with the FBI investigating
jokes one thing's for sure they left
Trevor Noah's account alone
at one point as many as 80 80 FBI agents
were tasked with patrolling the site
demanding anything they didn't like be
flagged or taken down it's good to see
they had extra time on their hands I I
guess they got sick of doing pre-dawn
raids of trump and his friends
now I wonder if those same agents
consider extortion a crime because I
have a suggestion then how about the
snot-nosed pimply faced brat who
published elon's private jet info on
Twitter here he is on some Public Access
Channel back in February talking about
what it will take to make him go away
what is your current demand relative to
musk what will it make for you to go
away and stop this
uh still a Tesla or fifty thousand
dollars I mean I'm not gonna up it
there's no need to
awesome
I haven't seen a Shakedown that bad
since security at the Caesars Palace
buffet had Michael Moore stand on his
head
oh let's see if any glazed hams would
fall out of his pockets
so will the FBI be on that kid's tail no
they're busy interrogating grannies from
January 6 or sending a team to harass
Mike Lindell
fortunately that guy will sleep through
anything
meanwhile more files released today
suggest the FBI may have preemptively
suppressed accurate news reports on the
hunter laptop story even before it got
published minus any real evidence that
it was linked to an Intel operation so
that's news but I wonder what the media
coverage of that was like
foreign
[Music]
must be footage from the WNBA playoffs
but yeah because you watch the games but
you can bet they covered all those
precious journalists who were suspended
for a week for violating terms of
service and also doxing musk they're
already back after a short time out and
in case you noticed no one noticed no
one cares in fact I'm beginning not to
care anymore the fact that the media
does care just shows you how desperate
they are for something to fill that
trump-sized hole that 45 Left Behind now
who fills that hole it's Musk take a
look at Adam's Schiff although it might
induce projectile vomiting
Schiff tweeted Elon Musk calls himself a
free speech absolutist to justify
turning a blind eye to hatred and
bigotry on Twitter but when journalists
report unfavorable news they are banned
without warning the Devotion to free
speech is apparently not that absolute
but the hypocrisy is musk tweeted back
quote thankfully you lose your
chairmanship very soon
by the way the best part
best part no Don't Clap yet
foreign
premature copulation
he ended the Tweet with your brain is
too small
the best part the irony is that Adam
schiff's brain is too small to let his
small brain stop him it's why the
Democrats keep him around he's their
idiot step child that makes everyone
else in the party appear like geniuses
you know I'm not sure if Adam Schiff was
dropped as a child but I wouldn't blame
his parents foreign
's guest she's got more Stones than a
criminal in the Old Testament Fox News
contributor kellyanne Conway
he'll kill you with kindness and
kindness is the name of his machete
former CIA operative in the host of
black files Declassified on Discovery
Science Channel Mike Baker
comedy clubs call him the owl because
they hear his name and ask who who
host of fox Across America Jimmy Fallon
snowmen describe her personality as
Frosty Fox News contributor tattoo
so Mike yeah I always feel bad when we
talk about this stuff because you have
you know you work for the government you
killed people you could kill me you keep
me around just because I make you laugh
uh what does it does it make you feel
bad that the intelligence Community has
developed recently a bad reputation or
do you think that is unfounded or do you
think it's founded nobody ever says
founded was that founded is it founded
yes yes it was it you know don't get
gruntled and it's not or disgruntled
well that's all we have time for
drive safely uh it's uh it's um it's not
recent that it's been developing like
this right
um and here's the here's the honest to
God's truth the FBI should have contact
with companies a variety of companies in
a variety of sectors including a Twitter
right what they should be doing in
concert with the Intel Community is when
they identify a hostile element that is
using our social media platforms for
their own good
they should work with the private sector
to identify that just like they should
work with the private sector to try to
get best practices in cyber security and
other things
what's happened though is obviously
wrong it's political and that's what's
hap the point is bias has it has now
invaded this process right and and once
you lose I mean look I've lived and
worked overseas in a variety of really
nasty places where
um every time there's a change in
government or a new dictator they
wholesale change the Intel organization
enforcement Hawaii exactly go ahead and
uh and and you can't live in an
environment like that and we do not want
that yeah the bureau the agency all
these these agencies have to be
apolitical and the only other thing I've
got to say about about this and and
involves musk is
honest to God The Angst that the
progressive Liberals are showing over
the realization that Twitter is no
longer their exclusive playground if if
I could bottle that angst yeah and serve
it over artisanal Ice uh and drink it on
a warm Summer's night on my porch I'd be
the happiest would you do that shirtless
I would that's hot yeah we're coming
yeah I'm thinking about it right now
kellyanne it's discussing it is an
interesting point it was like they
didn't take the ball and went go home we
took the ball from him and I say we I
didn't do anything but like it is what
Mike Mike is pointing out is maybe
that's why musk is now replacing Trump
in that kind of vein it's the most hated
man on Earth what do you think about all
this I think all of that look they had
it all to themselves for a while ever
since they kicked Trump off and a lot of
his followers left also and if you go
back you look at the content on Twitter
for the last year and a half it's just
been very left-wing but it's also been
very boring it's a bunch of people just
high-fiving each other my brilliant
colleague just wrote a piece it's like
you hate your brilliant colleague yeah
you're always calling him a trunk you
know behind his back on the inevitable
this one and so now they all want to go
to post I can't be here anymore because
Elon hurts my feelings I think Elon Musk
in saying he's going to leave Twitter I
hope he doesn't I hope he actually call
me I think he's gonna stay for you no I
think he's gonna stay she's not going to
be CEO yeah exactly because he's got
like electric cars to build and people
to send to space he's got other things
to do but I think he's also conveying
the people Greg who don't seem to have
other things to do other than live on
Twitter go do other things get some
fresh Alex Halo rents get out of that
bed take that mask off but then get the
phone out of here Molly John slow
whatever these people's names are
they're on Twitter all they live on
Twitter I say they should keep the masks
on
and that has nothing to do with covet
but I love what he's done because he
bought the company and I think people
didn't know what was going to happen all
based on the fact that they banned
Babylon B and that's why like if I was
ever going to be a billionaire Jimmy
that's how arbitrary I would use my
money wait you banned my favorite
account on buying your company it was
it's incred it's incredible isn't it
weird the FBI I mean the FBI is trolling
Twitter for jokes so obviously you're
safe hey girl
he's got a million no it's sad when I
was a little kid okay we used to go to
Six Flags there were these guys with
those FBI hats Federal bikini inspectors
yes and you might not get the reference
because you couldn't get on the rides at
Six Flags but those of us that were on
the lines okay great adventure it was a
great adventure a great adventure but
stick with me I trust those guys with
our Intel more than the FBI and that's
sad and I don't want to bag on the Intel
Community because believe me if my
laptop gets discovered I got big
problems right you know what I'm saying
I'm carrying a vial of arsenic right now
just in case
but this is where I'm having a hard time
with Elon Musk because here's the thing
okay he was trying to expose the
corruption on the other side of
ownership but by aligning himself with
political positions he's allowing them
to justify turning a blind eye towards
the work he's trying to accomplish like
when he says fire fouchy that's
political and a lot of people jump in on
that that's true and then they're like
you know we don't even have to listen to
this anymore it's just right-wing
strongman stuff so I think on one end
it's good that he's exposing the
corruption but I think on the other end
he's kind of discrediting himself in the
process so he should punt he read I
think he's like that part of that is the
this kind of red pilling he's going
through yeah and it's so new it's
happening in public like it's excited
everything he does is in public much
like you cat oh
and congratulations your community
service has now been completed so uh
do you know um I'm just waiting until
you're done who do you think okay so
obviously he's going to step aside
because that's he wouldn't have never
done a Twitter poll if if if uh they
they if he knew the out if he didn't
know the outcome right he knew what it
was going to be and he actually
exploited he exploited that opportunity
who should who should be the person
should it be another Visionary or should
it be somebody without a single idea
like Jimmy yeah it should be somebody
that we've never heard of yes so that
you can't get mad about it well then
okay Jimmy yeah
[Applause]
I will go to the prom with you thanks
kellyanne boom yeah
prom date
I would die for that I I get why he
doesn't want to do it because like he
bought it so he already won yeah
like when I beat Bob Bowser and N64 I
kind of stopped playing it that's why I
make a great president I'd be like vote
for me I really want to win and then
I'll leave you alone
yeah but that's the reason you need
somebody who because people will try
really hard though whoever it is
everyone's gonna do a deep dive and be
like this person dressed as Pocahontas
when they were in the sixth grade
they're a racist they can't do this no
matter who you are they're going to find
a problem so they have to find the most
boring person in the entire world to
sort of to sort of run things you should
just turn on Fox and Friends boom
I'm joking It's a Wonderful show
encourage everybody to get up externally
and watch it but I do think there's
there's something with what he's doing
right now the Twitter files that are
being released and then because look
there's no way he's going to turn this
around I mean even Elon Musk right I
give him a lot of credit for things he's
done but I don't know how he makes this
a profitable company so there may be
some element of if he can show a huge
degree of malfeasance within the company
that wasn't disclosed by the the get out
of the business there may be a chance I
don't know that I hope he sells tweets
though yeah he's great he's a great
Tweeter I don't really care that he has
a political comment here or there no
that's an exciting we don't need the
David Suiter of Twitter yeah I mean I
like no right and I like people who have
an opinion Thomas Jefferson said opinion
is power so let's have one but I don't
know if it matters who it is if it's
someone who's Anonymous or someone well
known I think now with his ownership
people are very nervous about what comes
next for that and you know what
conservatives have felt for a long time
we're censored we're Shadow banned we're
castigated we're denigrated people do it
to our faces it turns turns out they
were doing it behind our backs on social
media and you know people were very
worried about Greg that Elon Musk has
access to and will start revealing
direct messages yeah between them
Anthony Weiner and others yes I erased
ours don't worry thank you up next was
Shaquille fueled by greed when he worked
for bankman free